let's go to joe who joins us in
harrisburg pennsylvania joe
you're on the ramsay show hey hey ken
hey dr john how are you guys doing
we are having a blast what's it all
about for you today
okay so i'm 23. i just graduated college
in may
and i'm a i'm actually a personal
finance teacher it uses dave's high
school curriculum
oh great thank you my question is i have
12
500 left on my student loan and i do a
monthly budget
as i should as a personal finance
teacher i go um
yes but i i have it planned out that
i'll be debt-free
by the end of summer so end of august
that's how i haven't
it out because i'm still living at home
with my parents um
so i'm able to save a lot of money like
that i've already paid off like
um about twenty thousand dollars good
for you my question is though since they
are in deferment
until september and there's all this
talk about you know the possibility of
some
uh of the debt being forgiven like i'm
not planning on that
but would it be wrong of me to put my
money
in the savings account that i've
budgeted every month until september
in case it happens then once september
hits and it doesn't happen i just pay
that 12
500 off because my next step would be
buying a house
and i just would be an awful feeling in
my stomach if i could have ten thousand
gone
i could put that towards the house yeah
i you know that's a very logical
question john
and joe i'm going to tell you something
um there was a point in my life where it
was a possibility that i was going to be
able to dunk a basketball at least that
was
really that was the thought no no no it
never was a possibility
that i'm making my point here and i
don't think it's a possibility that the
government's gonna pay your loans off
i just don't see it happening i think i
think it's one in a million chance it
happens
uh but to answer your question answer
your question straightforward
it's not wrong you know but that's not
what we're gonna recommend
i don't think it's morally wrong it just
puts yourself in a temptation
to if you put that aside and you stop
the plan
a plan that you're to execute in just a
few months at the end of the summer
it creates all levels of temptation and
my colleague is far
uh far more qualified to talk about the
psychological there
and so that's why we're never going to
recommend that you do that but it's not
morally wrong
joe here's here's my heart on it you're
a smart guy
is that correct i i
i think so that's like the impossible
question i know i set you up here
so you are a smart guy you would be a
finance he's like uh
no job [ __ ] hey so
at the end of the day where i struggle
with this as a guy who
me and my wife have what seven degrees
between us
we had six figures of student loans and
then i started
con using student loans to consolidate
cars and credit i went bananas with
student loans
all right yeah here's the thing
nobody tricked me every i didn't i
didn't
i didn't count the cost i didn't sit
there and add them up every semester and
see what i
you know how deep the hole was but i
didn't know to do that
right so at the end was i kind of do to
it
but here's the thing i signed my name to
a piece of paper and that paper said hey
if you'll help me get through college
i'll pay you back
and so for me this is an integrity
question
and you are somebody who has a a
blessing and that your parents and you
get along you're allowed to stay there
and save up this money
and there's something in my soul that
wouldn't sleep right knowing that i
waited on the government to bail me out
of the choice that i made
an integrity decision that i signed a
piece of paper saying i'll pay you back
because you helped me get through school
and so you have the ability
to work really hard and be debt-free on
your own two feet
in a few months and there's a part of me
that
as a guy who's walked alongside students
for so many years what i'm gonna tell
you is
you're gonna have your head held high
brother and
if if you pay it all off in august and
september they say hey we're waving 10
grand
you're going to go you're going to turn
around what you're going to do
is like most americans should you're
going to get indignant you're going to
say wait a minute
i just worked my butt off to complete
the agreement that i
signed and you're just going to wipe and
then you're going to say well
so it is i stood up on my own two feet
and not paid it off you can join the
ken coleman grumpy old man club because
i paid mine off and my wife paid hers
off
married yeah and it's like i don't think
they should defer that i don't think
they should uh
get pay these things off i don't like it
i don't think it's right all right then
if you agree then keep walking it
forward
i just didn't want the fomo you know hey
you know what listen you're gonna have
fomo whether you
just learn now that fomo's a choice
right it's a choice that's a great call
and you know what else joe you're
rocking it man
yeah pay these things off you can still
live with mom and dad a little longer
and save up for that house payment or
whatever take your time
i gotta tell you this john it's very
normal but now being 46
having gone through the early 20s i got
married at 23.
okay yeah i get it
but you don't have to buy a house no
to prove that you're a success or that
you aren't a loser or whatever the
narrative
is joe doesn't have to be in a hurry to
buy a house not that it's man if you if
you get an apartment at 23 you're just
pouring your money down the drain you're
just flushing it down the toilet
no you're not no you're not you learn
how to grow up you're saving some money
outside of mom and dad's house
right and we're not talking about you
joe talking about anybody who's 23
man and you have the opportunity to live
at home it's a it's a healthy situation
you pay those loans off really fast
and then go live in an apartment for a
few years yeah slow down
save your money let this market cool off
have cash in your hand and go put down
20 30 40 percent on a house when people
need to get out you're gonna get a great
deal on a house
yeah just everybody exhale for a second
especially you 22 23
24 year olds yeah i mean renting is not
a sin we got to say that
over and over and over